para muchos epidemiólogos y analistas la
respuesta es no porque hay quien dice
incluso que jair bolsonaro es el
verdadero ministro de sanidad de brasil
y quiere un ministro sumiso que acate
sus órdenes y que son básicamente no
hacer un lock down porque él siempre lo
ha dicho no quiere que pare la economía
que y droga es el presidente de la
sociedad brasileña de cardiología y es
un viejo conocido de jair bolsonaro de
hecho en 2018 después de las elecciones
presidenciales que eroga participó en el
equipo de transición dando apoyo técnico
en temas de salud ahora en una
entrevista reciente que eroga ha dicho
que está a favor de la vacunación en
contra de la polémica hidroxi cloroquina
el medicamento que siempre apoyó
bolsonaro y cuya eficacia ha sido
descartada por muchos por la mayoría de
los médicos sabemos que la semana pasada
por el efecto lula
o sea cuando lula fue y no sentado y dio
un discurso hubo una ligera cambio un
ligero cambio de actitud tanto en él
como en su familia a sus hijos y
empezaron a apoyar la refundación en las
redes sociales él apareció usando una
máscara una mascarilla y él sabe que sin
bajar el número de muertos y sin bajarlo
el número de muertos no puede aspirar a
la reelección pero es de esperar que
este nuevo ministro solo va a funcionar
con el presidente sacará sus órdenes y
si no tendrá que dimitir